human dignity the right to religion
freedom of speech these are just a few
basic principles enshrined in the EU
Charter of Fundamental Rights but with
discrimination on the rise across the EU
how brittle have these rights become the
state of play on fundamental rights is
that it is always complex anyway but
known 2015 it's become even more complex
because we have this tension now between
getting the balance right between
fundamental rights on the one hand and
security on the other we need to really
calibrate where we are the recent spate
of terror attacks by the so-called
Islamic state has filled Islamophobia
europe-wide but illegal migration and
the economic crisis have also had a hand
in increasing intolerance and
discrimination we proposed to apply the
Justice Corps board also to monitoring
better the situation of the protection
of human rights in each member state and
to evaluate if there is a need of an
intervention of action Europe as first
vice president of the Commission frans
timmermans pointed out is a continent of
destination for so many but has failed
to adapt the question now is whether the
tide can be changed to make the EU a
more credible caretaker of freedoms